after we pay the initial Intel cost to
make contact we'll have to scan the
region for a few days before the local
resistance cell comes out of time once
we find them we'll be up and running in
the new region
commander using Intel collected so far
we've managed to locate a resistance
cell operating out of this region it'll
take us some time to scan for their
exact position though attempting to
establish local regional contact nothing
on the local coms Advent some quiet
lately I'm guessing we have you to thank
for that
our pleasure den mother enjoy it while
it lasts
we plan to a lot of purification signal
coming from the Advent Network tower its
global so I think you want to see this
fellow citizens for 20 years the Advent
Coalition has worked tirelessly to
repair the ravages and in Justices of
the old world under our stewardship our
cities prosper our people flourish and
our world he and yet among us there are
still those who would refuse to
acknowledge the truth who are determined
to see all that we have achieved trouble
radar contacts on approach to Haven
alpha 7
good and coming on imposing on you're
breaking up
territory to end this scourge once and
for all
if I don't touch you losing you Avenger
have a chance with sure your continued
safety to wealthy to help describe your
primal of your cooperation leave the
Cobra cons radical elements tonight
arrange another twenty years of peace
and prosperity they don't stand a chance
commander we should get a squad ready to
deploy commander we have a squad ready
to move on the resistance Haven
currently under siege by the aliens give
the word and we'll move out
commander we have a mission available
that's reliant on time-sensitive
information we can always finish our
scans later but failing to take on this
mission could have serious repercussions
for the resistance movement
setting course for the eastern US
precinct not think I could have
predicted this outcome doget is
intriguing
knowing that my past surgical experience
is limited I am sure the crew
appreciates that I hone my skills on
fallin Advent forces before triaging our
own wounded to the uninitiated
the common Advent trooper is seemingly
human the aliens have decided that the
most glaring divergence from the human
form with a carefully designed helmet
[Music]
dr. shins constant vigil look I already
message coming through commander putting
it on screen now you have made
considerable progress against the aliens
over the past month commander I hope
that your ongoing efforts will only lead
to further success commander we have
Intel suggesting the aliens are working
on developments that threaten our
ability to stop the Avatar project we
can conduct guerrilla operations to
disrupt one of these efforts but we'll
have to choose carefully we don't have
the resources to intercede everywhere
commander the resistance has a hidden
cache of resources stashed outside of
advents reach but that means we'll have
to fly over and scan the area if we want
to recover this stuff for ourselves
commander we'll need to completely scan
this region before we can establish
contact with the local resistance I'd
advise we stick around and finish the
job but the choice is yours
setting course for sector 9 western
United States
you
gyrate Menace ready to deploy we just
picked up an emergency signal from one
of the resistance camps the aliens are
sweeping the whole area taking out
anyone they can find we're moving in to
put a stop to it and protect as many
people as we can secure the site and
neutralize all hostile contacts
menace 1-5 hostile forces are attacking
the outpost eliminate all enemy units
and protect those civilians Advent came
in hot and so did we
you won't have a concealed position for
deployment on this one getting it done
the resistance managed to recover and
restore a handful of these mobile
communications jammers over the years
with a few makeshift repairs these
things have proven invaluable to the
resistance effort get back to the ship
double-time go get outta here not at
first Advent deployed non-lethal stun
units for crowd control in the
occasional protest we don't see a whole
lot of that anymore
what track meaning wiser
ten-four
they're all over me
what's in might nothing it's nothing
affirmative moving out come on hustle
good copy
moving on target open for society
hostiles coming in from sight
I'm alright
we're losing civilians left and right
commander we need to get these people
out of here
[Applause]
heading out
heads down
biggest for you nothing give me out of
here please
that was close
stepping off go on get going
I'm under fire
it's a little ugly
closing on target position now our
Styles pacified
closing on target position now target
disabled
you
[Music]
at an urgent communication coming in for
you now commander I had high hopes for
the resistance under your leadership
commander and you have outdone yourself
commander we have Intel suggesting the
aliens are working on developments that
threaten our ability to stop the Avatar
project we can conduct guerrilla
operations to disrupt one of these
efforts but we'll have to choose
carefully we don't have the resources to
intercede everywhere commander the
resistance has a hidden cache of
resources stashed outside of advents
reach but that means we'll have to fly
over and scan the area if we want to
recover this stuff for ourselves
[Music]
[Music]
object is added commander we've
established contact with the local
resistance and we can move on the Advent
black site on your order we should make
sure our troops are fully equipped and
ready for a tough mission
I'm guessing security will be tight at
the facility we're making progress
commander I've updated our objectives
based on the latest findings avenger
plotting new course
I appreciate the new lab facilities
commander
[Music]
commander we have a priority message
hello commander it would seem your
recent activities have gotten advents
attention our unwelcome guests are on
the move
Advent has been diverting considerable
resources of personnel to covert
facilities across the globe the exact
details of these operations are highly
classified however they do have one
thing in common a single word that
appears in all their files avatar
I believe the black site we had
previously uncovered to be but a part of
this Avatar project we're tracking the
aliens progress on this Avatar project
here if they finish what they've started
sounds like it'll be the end for all of
us to aid in your efforts we have
gathered additional resources and staff
at resistance headquarters for your use
I have to admit there is something
exciting
commander I appreciate you recruiting
new staff for the engineering team but
as it stands we have people still
waiting for an assignment we can have
them working on construction excavation
or staffing a facility
commander I'm going to need more help on
the engineering team before I can start
clearing out some of the other room we
should recruit an engineer
Avenger plotting new course
setting course for eastern United States
guy Ranger deployed we're in the pipe
five by five our contacts in the local
resistance have shown us how to access
the Advent black site
the aliens worked hard to keep this
place under the radar and we don't know
what we're gonna find in there keep your
heads up expect heavy opposition
we've confirmed the black site is in
your immediate vicinity infiltrate and
investigate the area expect heavy
resistance neutralize all hostile
contacts the Alexis's position
Oh
who knows how long they've been keeping
these storage units running down here
will do
running
good tickle notation concerned there are
two us will do nothing English
at first Advent deployed non-lethal stun
units for crowd control in the
occasional protests we don't see a whole
lot of that anymore move it out stay
clear of those turrets we're still not
entirely sure if they're fully automated
or remotely triggered 108 is 4 subsided
I need some help
hostile neutralized
solid copy
this is for you
II
running already that
on it
move in on target location moving to
designated coordinates
what is confirmed on the move
Roger that
ed in their life I think I hear
something
Otis confound on the nose
[Music]
at first Advent deployed non-lethal stun
units only occasional protests we don't
see a whole lot of that anymore
affirmative move it out
grenade move into designated position
Crosstown neutralized
how is cool watch the flanks
are you guys
don't my brain just like me ain't coming
fire Markel stick go do that
just target utilized
bums away still moving catch keep the
pressure on
position confirmed stay clear of those
turrets we're still not entirely sure if
they're fully automated or remotely
triggered
closing on target position now
enemy eliminated good to go already
there
good to go good outfit here
it's still moving on the move
ready to engage
it's down incoming fire damn it banks
and cover you're all over me
I can't move
enemy down top it
hostile neutralized
you
dog is eliminated starting to lose
ground
on the move
Roger that
moving house hold on are those bodies
the containers and the trains this
entire facility
the aliens are still abducting people
from the looks of it they may never have
stopped after the invasion those
containers look like they have self
contained power cells it could be some
kind of stasis system it's possible at
least some of those people might still
be alive
get it done
[Music]
location concerns
got it moving
efficiency
just subject for some sort of weapon
perhaps looks more like a refinery to me
doctor once we get our hands on that
sample we'll know for sure
affirmative got it moving
moving out this is an extremely
well-equipped mechanized combat unit
we'll need to look for vulnerabilities
is going to take that thing out
hit the armour on the move
kento
affirmative moving out
moving to overwatch got some up in here
taking fire over here hey coming over
here
enemy destroyed
it's down might be something we could
use here
movie
young yourself Terry mosses here no no
no no please
[Music]
hostiles pacified I'm running low on
ammo heavy fire in the Sun
adjusting sights understood moving out
you heard the doctor secure that
canister I know they're all over me
I'm ready moving moving good to go shot
wide
that was close files reading typing out
I think to that location
nailed him
stepping off
I'm all over it
stepping off I've got it
guessing that's not water in there Jen
any readings no signs of radioactivity
no significant energy signatures of any
kind whatever it is it's safe to handle
we've confirmed acquisition of the
sample moved to rendezvous with the
extraction point
Buddhism coming in
location confront
Advent forces on the ground
got it moving got it
solid copy
no we're telling no this isn't right
just listen try taking heavy fire
who's got a medkit
or disconfirmed
moving out
b-back confirms
no need to ask twice I'm going
on the moon I'm going Avenger
this is firebrand packages secure all
surviving XCOM operatives are secure
firebrand returning to base
mission accomplished commander we just
had out that where it hurts